who
would like to earn some money
[Applause]
can i can i say something by the way
hold on one second hold on hold on
while you guys are pointing can i say
one thing
can i ask you a question
why did you trail off like you jumped
off a cliff you were like i wanna be a
stripper
[Applause]
i was like did somebody push her off of
a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
oh okay whatever
but wait a second okay
so
the question still [ __ ] remains why
did you why were you like
uh okay so we need three people from
three different hold on i i need someone
who's going first of all
it can't be all women i need at least
one dude come on santa
he just he just ho ho ho'd so
all right santa
who else who want do you want to come on
up here
come on arkansas
hey don't drop out any kids while you're
up here all right
[Applause]
are you coming up bro
we need i need one more i need one more
all right come on come on you're up here
all right so here's what we're going to
do can you just push that stuff to the
back my man
here's what we're going to it's hard to
see right
so here's what we're going to do guys
we're going to have you come up um
you're all going to stand behind me and
this is you're going to do interpretive
dance
to us this song now this is not who's
the best dancer this is
who feels the music in the lyrics
and shows that now what before we do
that we're going to eat meet each one of
you
so
santa come up here first
i got three questions for all of you and
then um
okay
santa
this is fine right here let me ask you a
question so we gonna refer to 42 nope
uh
are we going to refer to you as santa's
are you any sure okay so your name is
santa santa i need and remember these
questions
i need to know on a scale of one to ten
one being elaine from seinfeld and 12.
hold on one second shut the [ __ ] up and
remember that you're not funny you're
going on the nutty list
santa santa dude i just need you to
answer the questions
okay all right here we go
on a scale of that [ __ ] this
on a scale of zero to ten
zero being elaine from seinfeld 10 being
michael jackson pre-pedophile
oh too soon sorry all right uh
how do you rate yourself as a dancer
[Music]
what are the odds that i'm talking to
you when i'm looking at him four
four
okay you know i like this i like this
strategy
because you know i think you're gonna
for us but you're gonna come out a
strong seven and people are gonna be
like all right
santa's shaking that sack all right here
we go
all right now two more questions
remember these questions
in one word
how would you describe
your dancing athletic sexy like one word
how would you describe it naughty
oh
all right
and last one santa last one
what is the name of your best dance move
the candy cane that's a [ __ ] really
good one dude
give me the mic that's your [ __ ]
you better figure out a candy cane
before you start dancing bro
so we let children remind each other
this is santa
santa's a solid four
he dances naughty
and his best move is the [ __ ] candy
cane
which i assume is your best move too so
all right come on up here arkansas
what's your name
ashley ashley yes of course it is
what does that mean
ashley on a scale of one to ten how
would you rate yourself as a dancer
an eight an eight i think
the same amount of kids as she is a
dancer
every kid her store went up two is the
difference three is the dancer i'm a
better dancer four five so
man you have two more kids you're gonna
be a [ __ ] you're gonna be chris brown
up here all right
okay
so ashley is an eight ashley give me one
word to describe your dance style
drop it drop it oh i'll take it we'll
hyphenate that
but ashley don't disappoint us
by the way ashley wait wait a second
one last what is the name of your best
dance move
remember these questions
anything you can think of anything
yes
booty shake booty shake all right there
you go all right by the way amanda i
think all of us
are scared of you doing this one time
so don't do the dropping up here because
no i meant i just i didn't want a baby
to fall out
come on up here young lady
what is your name carolina carolina
carolina on a scale of one to ten
santa's a four ashley's an eight
what would you consider yourself as a
dancer i'm gonna go with a five a five
yo she's under underselling herself
isn't she she's good she's gonna come
out smoking i know all right okay
carolina give me one word
you would use to describe your dance
style miscellaneous miscellaneous
it all depends on the drink let me tell
you something by the way i had one guy
his name was i go he was a bro he came
up here he was dancing around like i
just been called on the [ __ ] price is
right and he was like
i think what's your name man is clint
i go clinton right yourself as a dancer
he goes four
i go what's word
i go what's one word to describe your
dance style he goes aggressive
[Applause]
he was right he was [ __ ] aggressive
as [ __ ]
right carolina you are a five i mean as
a dancer and
what would you say that one word is
miscellaneous and tell me your best
dance move
salsa salsa
okay
now here's what we're going to do
everybody uh there are just so you know
two rounds to this
do you want to hear the song you'll be
dancing to
do not dance yet don't show everybody
your moves
but you just want to hear them remember
you're feeling the music
you're feeling it's not who's the best
dancer it's
who feels it the most
we're gonna go one at a time santa
you're gonna go first but not yet don't
do don't do that you're making me
nervous
oh by the way there are a couple rules
where i need to start first rule no
touching me
i had to make that rule after the first
time we did this i was like i had about
nine bowls on my leg so
no touching me
no touching each other
no props no picking up anything on the
stage you can touch yourself all you
want santa i think
we all kind of expected that was gonna
happen um
okay
this is the song santa don't dance yet
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
not yet you're good all right all right
so you're gonna come out one at a time
i'm just gonna play that first verse
santa
now listen don't
you know don't drop the sack on the
first time you know you don't want to
blow you
save a little bit because you might be
into the second round that goes by
although it goes by audience vote so i
think you got no shot but here we go
you ready get it get it man ready
[Music]
did he just [ __ ]
[Applause]
is he just gonna bust out some new kids
on the block moves
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we may have underestimated santa
only a form all right but now you're
already an eight standing like that man
all right ready
all right ready
[Music]
when
[Music]
[Applause]
all right santa
now look
ashley you don't have to do that you can
be ethereal just feel what does this
music mean to you
listen there's a lot to do after that
but let me ask you something when you
say i don't know what to do after that
does that mean he stole the moves you
were gonna do oh okay
so
that's listen just feel the music let me
tell you something i want to say
something right now to all three of you
and i mean this from the bottom of my
heart man i stand up on these stages
every night
the the balls it took for the three of
you to come up here i just want you know
how much
i i want you to know honestly how much
respect i have for that i know what it
takes to come up here you and you guys
are coming up here you didn't come to
the show like i'm gonna be on stage
tonight you know
dancing to the back street boys you know
so let me just take it somewhere now
have you ever done anything like this
before no
[ __ ] win already i'm telling you
right now
this is a [ __ ] win for you already
i and i will tell you something else
they like you it does they like you
all right so just
[Applause]
arkansas is right
somebody throw their teeth up here make
her feel better
[Applause]
are you ready
okay we love you you're the best here we
go
okay
that's the best part do you think he
knew what he was doing
not until the end then you knew what you
were doing
all right here we go
[Applause]
you ready
you ready
[Music]
she's right your friend is right
let me tell you something right now what
a [ __ ] story this is going to be
kick these people on the [ __ ] nuts
ashley here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i
want it that way
[Applause]
ashley
i'm not gonna lie to you that certainly
felt like a i've never done this before
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] nailed that
[Applause]
young lady carolina
great job
carolina come on up here now listen
a5
miscellaneous
we just had this conversation i'm
telling you
it's now i will tell you this i'm gonna
whisper something to you
okay
[Applause]
i don't know what she said but it
tickled when she whispered in my ear
i was like okay
[Laughter]
all right you ready do you want the
you want to change sides
all right do i need to move that water
[Applause]
shit's about to get real
you ready
[Music]
when i
santa
has a heart on
[Applause]
santa
came in his pants
santa's dick's name is rudon
all right everybody now it's time by the
way where are you at
[ __ ] yeah
all right now listen now is the time
where we narrow it down to two
and then when we do two they both dance
at the same time and it's up to you guys
to vote so i'm gonna point to them and
you're gonna by crowd response
you're gonna tell me
how you thought they did
santa
[Applause]
all right i'm guessing i know how this
is going to go
ashley
hey
thank you so much brother i really
appreciate it so much santa everybody
come on one time for this dude
and let me tell you something man about
you specifically dude one of the reasons
i asked you to go first is because
look i knew that you would just give it
and they needed to everybody needed to
see that it was all right so thank you
so much dude i appreciate you coming up
and putting your balls out here
but i appreciate you not putting your
balls out here you know what i mean
ladies
now is the time
miscellaneous salsa
drop it booty shaker
now might be the time
to bring out your special moves
i will play the song for as long as i
can remember how the song goes
you guys will dance it out
and then the winner
will earn their server
some money from me
[Music]
[Applause]
and then oh hold on one second
i i um i didn't always sell merch but um
we bought a house so much
well let me just do this real quick so i
have some of the old school
i like weird [ __ ] shirts
[Applause]
i probably didn't need to show you that
one um
and uh the new the new ones these are
the new one
[Music]
i i have a couple of the high life
shirts left
and then um these are just the shirts
that i
these are just what i like to this is
how i like to live so i bring these
wherever i go
uh and these i got these in a couple
different ways all right
all right so uh yeah yeah you guys
definitely know
all right let me take a drink of this
are you guys ready
yeah you guys ready
[Applause]
here we go
remember
you can touch each other as long as you
get consent it's 20 21.
i don't have any consent forms up here
but we'll take some mental consent
[Music]
okay here we go you guys ready
[Music]
i
i can't speak to
your
[Music]
tell me why
[Music]
[Applause]
away
it seemed like they got a little too
nice to each other at the end yeah
all right so listen
listen by the way
let him hear it one time that was
[ __ ] great
and now
now and so
carolina who was your server
ricky
ashley who's your server
who's your sir
brendan
it's a girl
okay is her name brandon
okay so andrea and ricky
all right
okay
so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna vote again
this is ricky
this is andrea
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we'll give them both money
ashley and carolina everybody then i'm
here one time
[Music]
[Music]
you